let's talk about what's going on on our
reddit discussion forum always like to
check in there and see what's happening
david pakman.com slash reddit re d di t
now more than 2,100 of our our viewers
regularly discussing politics there too
popular topics me taking off my shirt
and whether i trust the CIA came up on
the reddit discussion forum over the
last week let's take a look at a few of
the stories starting with anti-trump
elector Chrissa prune paid for Ashley
Madison while bankrupt and married with
three kids this is a story that surface
to try to smear this Republican Trump
elector who announced he wouldn't be
voting Trump and my response was what
difference does it make what difference
does it make whether christopher supreme
was cheating if he feels that he should
not be voting for Donald Trump which is
something he can decide as an elector
another discussion from our ready
discussion forum why is david pakman
trusting the CIA all of a sudden they
were after all very wrong about iraq
listen uh i've made it very clear that
that is a false talking point okay we
have a situation where the George W Bush
administration misused the intelligence
from the CIA the CIA never actually said
hey we've got all the stuff that we know
for sure Saddam has that is a false
talking point from the right and you
should be aware of it another discussion
from reddit at david pakman.com slash
read it Trump Secretary of State
favorite Rex Tillerson praised the
trans-pacific partnership yeah a few
people have emailed me about this thing
David you know now that TPP is dead
supposedly tillerson is a guy who liked
it that may well be true I don't know
that tillerson praising TPP in the past
means it's going to be revived under
under Trump but we will see next
discussion from our reddit discussion
forum ideas to spice up the fundraiser
this was an interesting post with some
ideas for what we might be able to do on
the fundraiser of course mentioned in
there is that quote a lot of people seem
to want David to take his shirt off so
there is that also a lot of people
really want to see Louis well I'll say
two things about that number one I don't
know that a lot of people want to see me
take my shirt off I've I've heard it
from two people so far one via voicemail
and one on
it and that may actually be the same
person and number two as far as Louis
Louis will be on today's bonus show he
is on his exploratory trip to the
southeast of the United States hoping to
find a new place to live uh and we're
going to be hearing from producer louis
today just to connect those two points
is it true that producer louis once took
his shirt off on the show I think it is
I don't know that it was that he took
his shirt off but I think he had on a
hoodie and a t-shirt under it and he
wanted to show the t-shirt or maybe it
was to show his tattoos and in the
process of taking off maybe maybe just
the hoodie he exposed a significant
portion of his his entire torso and I
know that memberships exploded that day
the only day that we've done that better
on worship bad today was the day after
Donald Trump was elected into a 16 so
clearly was a big big deal okay I think
we have one or two more do we what one
more one more story but somebody posted
some hilarious photo shops of Donald
Trump is the queen of England but with
the full hat and everything you have to
see these these are very very visual
these are really good aren't they Pat I
mean these are fantastic pictures yet
have you ever seen clump a combination
of Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton
together I have one face that's
fantastic it's the stuff of nightmares I
mean it's a very very scary so anyway
all of these discussions and more
happening at david pakman.com slash
reddit i'm on there regularly I see Pat
mixing it up in the discussion forum as
well so check it out sign up and it's
all going to be very very exciting and
continuing there